give it a push give them a push the rock
giving you a [ __ ] flush turn this
into a gift the push all you need is a
push and this is an Instagram story take
over and get ready full-day action
comment my big ambition is to be an all
time entrepreneur by both my success in
my career but what has become more
evident to people I think recently is
also by influencing as many people as
possible in a positive way so that they
get theirs and that means the person
that goes from the job that they're not
excited about to making a tea for you
know thousand sterling a year being
happy talking about their proper
football team on Instagram and YouTube
to the young gal right now in Sweden
who's gonna start up five hundred
million dollar you know media company so
I think to be the great entrepreneur of
this generation there's clearly the
bezos's and and the Elon Musk's and the
sucks I don't think I'm gonna be able to
create that kind of wealth
I just want to create obnoxious amount
of wealth but you know a billion dollars
in a billion people I think puts you
above everybody else and and I think
that is where my behavior is right now
like why am i doing this podcast the
State of the Union of attention and
associate world car brick road be green
all right right it's yellow
I have no idea how many people watch it
or listen to this I'm gonna guess it's a
hell of a lot less than the Wall Street
Journal or the BBC or other people that
chase me I think in a goal to reach as
many people as possible you have to do
multiple things you have to give back to
people who are actually doing things
yeah so that they can leverage your name
and get more guests and that's what I'm
doing here hey how are you baby sing it
hey Ben okay how are you hi how are you
hey David good to see you oh sorry my
friend you miss my sweater
how are you I'm good good how are you
good to see you how are you good great
and also if it's 17 or 1700 or 17,000
every you know you never know which
niches in which different places where
you may catch somebody so I'm tirelessly
trying to bring value by being
historically correct on my points of
view on culture and attention and in
business and that's who I am
are you building one are you building a
private brand or a private label yet
correct you should so I think at this
point at that revenue the other big
debate you should be having at home is
okay so so the most important thing for
everybody in this room is the customer
there is nothing else everything else is
secondary you have the most important
part you at the beginning the
manufacturers and your suppliers have
the leverage then you have the leverage
so now you have the leverage what allows
you to start looking at the ability for
you to create a signature product that
you own forever which is much more IP
which has dramatically more economic
impact long-term and should 100% be a
parallel highway in your brains as you
continue to try to go from five to ten
from 13 percent margin to 20 or from 40%
margin to 60 in parallel not separate in
parallel you need to be thinking about
okay if we're gonna start a private
label what are we gonna call it how are
we gonna make it
what are we gonna make because it's not
going to be hyper fashion it's going to
be iconic you're gonna try to be in the
Louis Vuitton Cartier Tiffany business
versus what you're doing now but you
have the most important asset which is
the attention of the end consumer that
equates to five million dollars in
revenue which is a meaningful thing I'm
ambitious about what's going on here
we're close closer than you think and so
please don't let lack of communication
be the vulnerability of you not getting
the benefit of it because that is it
you're getting close to going to the
next place you never you never thought
you could afford to pay somebody
$150,000 a year to be the lead designer
but now you could back to what are your
actual ambitions I would argue that's
what I would do but that's because I'm
trying to go here you need to understand
where you need to be you're already at a
place please go ahead got one [ __ ]
life do something about it it's all
about alternatives
you know when it's hard for you and I
doing our thing my simple question is
what would you rather be doing like you
really want to go work for somebody else
instead we eat [ __ ] 24/7 but it's better
than the alternative and that's how we
keep it happy
great see you again keep buying k-swiss
yeah it's such a pleasure yeah seriously
real talent like it thank you yes when
you're 25 yes today yes we yes Yeah
right
yeah there's no wrong yeah
go take the corner to live humbly and
taste valuing anybody's opinion beside
yourself is the biggest [ __ ] mistake
of all time [ __ ] his developer friends
your [ __ ] is [ __ ] OnPoint go do your
thing don't listen to anybody but what's
in your [ __ ] mind and the [ __ ]
heart go get yours
Zoe Tyler does anybody bring me a beanie
I want to put that there
but everybody one [ __ ] life do
something do something like this man did
listen learn they go what are you scared
of somebody's opinion with stakes the
upside gotta try things you gotta be
committed to one week one day to the
jobs you just got a shake yeah DM people
you admire yeah coffees jobs more
completely got it yes yeah but up
YouTube you guys live in or you [ __ ]
let's go go get yours baby stop [ __ ]
listening to anybody but your head and
your [ __ ] heart nobody not your
brother not your parents not society
listen your [ __ ] self go get it you
gotta be patient about it's a big
message brother I say the same [ __ ]
every day for 10 years listen who you
talking to
[ __ ] you think I'm up to
you understand just don't don't be it
doesn't mean anything you're gonna
regret it
just go got it how do you get legacy
later there's only one way to get like
you see the band you got to give more to
them than you take the more you give the
less you take the more you can have
legacy do you understand [ __ ] 123
that's the biggest thing that scares me
that you don't realize you can do
nothing right for 10 years and then
still be young you have to understand
don't yes me understand it you can
[ __ ] once again you can literally
literally live for next 10 years do
nothing right and [ __ ] with you're
putting too much pressure on yourself
you're either trying to prove it to
somebody or to yourself
but you've got to slow it down you don't
know what you want nobody [ __ ] knows
what they want at 23 you got time got
[ __ ] time baby you understand your
kid decisions really quickly because I
know that I will never know what the
other alternative was so I'm not
crippled by being perfect I would DM
every single person in the industry and
people that are winning on YouTube and
Instagram and offer your services for
free until ship hop when you don't have
money or relationships you have time
yeah you blood deploy it by not worrying
about you about other people judging me
I'm not worried about what a parent Stan
you could make every [ __ ] decision in
the world when you close out everybody
else's opinion first higher should take
away from your luxuries not put you out
of business
yeah you understand give out the luxury
100% the advice is very simple when you
listen to other people's opinions you
slow down your [ __ ] destiny go
[ __ ] get it one at bat swing it swing
it but I also don't think that that one
bad experience means that you can try
again don't overreact patience and
execution you can too many people get a
little success and start worrying about
scale way too prematurely you're going
to scale the same way you got it off the
ground the first place
patience don't worry about raising
capital don't worry about that [ __ ]
patience I'm grateful we got a chance we
got a chance that's how I stay motivated
there's no [ __ ] alternative you know
how I tell people to taste things just I
ran a [ __ ] liquor stores
I ran the e-commerce wine business the
farthest thing from my [ __ ] mind was
starting flog about wine in 2006 but
then I tasted something and it changed
my [ __ ] life maybe you're the best
surfer in the world
maybe the best caviar [ __ ] chef on
the planet
you got a try [ __ ] when you're this
young for example you're letting
everything around you suck you into
something you don't have to do
just become great then talk about it
only because your ambitions greater
which I commend you on you already know
that you're doing loser moves so my
bigger question is you [ __ ] know so
why would you let yourself do that
you're gonna be like I don't know I
don't get it but [ __ ] stop watch this
video every day stop [ __ ] deploy
patient the beginning you work for free
and you get all the money execute
inspire through your actions not by you
trying to convince them I mean go out
and become successful on something that
isn't based on convincing them and let
them see it just stopping every time
you're over one yeah don't judge
yourself does it so when you're tired go
to sleep don't judge yourself don't
judge yourself and to try it but it's
literally basic [ __ ] but I'll triple it
down the way you're good at just be
honest with yourself I [ __ ] do he's
back easy money is dangerous money
looking back would you be your dwelling
they're worried about what happened it's
over so what do you think before you
sleep every night that I'm grateful that
everybody I love this alive and where we
go the same thank you to the fight yes
we will that's a good hat that was well
done what a delight what up
one life's fellows use that chip on your
shoulder as your [ __ ] advantage stop
dwelling and start focusing life's about
a very simple [ __ ] option these are
do you know if you're gonna [ __ ] eat
[ __ ] under that roof you need to put
your [ __ ] ear pods in and listen to
positive and 24/7 to get that [ __ ] you
understand when your surroundings are
[ __ ] your insides got to be positive in
fact you're even here means you're
[ __ ] halfway home
[Music]
so no [ __ ] choice either you're gonna
what are you gonna lose my friend we're
alive
dude how special that is stop [ __ ]
wasting go get your brother get the [ __ ]
up get the [ __ ] up this is your at-bat
I'm so blessed that you can wake the
[ __ ] up get the [ __ ] up you're never
just bullshitting
just right the audio make it lower ah be
one life do something about it
[ __ ] put in the work stop [ __ ] go
try we're very upset with you can but
you're not here can where the [ __ ] are
you put in the [ __ ] work and shut the
[ __ ] up I'm 20 years older than you and
I feel just like you you've got time
crushing it is actually more about
patience than you think be thoughtful be
smart I've met kids here today that made
100k in two minutes in Bitcoin and lost
it three months later he asked me why no
he asked me why and I told him because
fast money is dangerous money be patient
all those young people out there trying
to figure out this stuff wanting to make
it happen
what do they do the problem is is you
let somebody else's opinion dictate your
behavior while you're figuring it out
let me let me let me break the news to
you 99% of people in their 20s didn't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing
99% of people that in their 90's don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing stop
judging yourself everybody else is doing
it for you just taste try learn hustle
do the right thing like [ __ ] just work
hard to be patient and don't worry that
you've got to figure it now to stick it
to your older brother because he's more
successful or your parents that said you
never the only people that win
are the people that win when the score
is over everybody in their 20s is trying
to win the first quarter it's a four
quarter game and you just it's a [ __ ]
marathon people think I [ __ ] did this
yesterday this is take my whole [ __ ]
life while you're complaining I'm taking
your [ __ ] remember that
thank you means the world to me Sasha B
where are you Bard what the [ __ ] does
that a put out great content yeah you
got to be patient
you got a DM people the problem is you
want to get too big too fast maybe your
whole [ __ ] life God did brother when
you start asking questions how long it's
gonna take you they'll never get there
yeah yeah it's about loving the process
of getting it
I can't wait to [ __ ] win and mean do
you know why I love mainland China not
because it has so many people it's
because nobody knows who the [ __ ] I am I
love the process about the future you're
trying to get too big too fast yeah
which is why you won't get big do it for
nine years be 28 younger too [ __ ]
shitty be right over here I know he's in
there it's all for the taking so happy
stop dwelling and start taking stop
[ __ ] dwelling and start taking expect
your pops and number two respect
yourself more yes stop start listening
to fewer voices greatest era to be
making music ever very simply because
there's no [ __ ] middle man stopping
you your [ __ ] dwelling about
algorithms and Spotify this it's the
[ __ ] greatest heroes get yours
[ __ ] make the music put it out get it
one life do something about it say
things like I do like them but they
don't think I'm 24 but this is what I
feel respective addresses do anything
the best way to be awesome is give more
to others and be patient that's how you
get it
see you guys later take care thank you
for coming versus stuff and all that
yeah and I'll take it from there okay
all right thank you great to see you in
the end baby Johnny you better be
patient
Johnny listen to me moments we live for
everybody forget about this piece of
this clip I'm not givin to him
use this to put pressure on him to be
patient that's pretty actually
I miss Wang right this I told you and
like I've started I saw that coming out
depression I'm forcing myself off the
ride good I'm using vlogging and
documenting good because I saw it like
if you like but you say it's true you
know but I don't know what I'm doing it
right like I feel like voguing is the
way documenting right now it's the way I
totally agree of everything and I hope
this like generate income so that I can
do and do something today I also wanted
to is I think the world can change right
one is health technology at Simon
technology and the value the world is
too heavy
yeah the world you know good the world
is yeah the world doesn't need to change
yeah don't cubes have had a good we're
still here the world's great our
perspectives on the world is the key
however you await the chemicals the
circumstance put you here now what's
incredible is that you have the ambition
to tweak it that you listen a lot of
times when I see my crew with the people
I exam with I'm already optimistic about
you because you signed up you're trying
to twist whatever is not working you
understand that right you understand
that you can't fix the way you were
parented it's where you grew up and what
happened - I'm just trying before I get
it I just don't know if I'm doing the
right
I feel like the good news is whatever
you did in the early part is what's
making you insecure whether it's the
right thing the more you do pattern
recognition the more you do the more you
do you become more of it like listen the
biggest thing I would tell all of you if
if I what I what you know and I've never
actually said this the biggest thing I'm
observing right now is what my mom did
for me I'm in a small way doing for
others like like like what what it's
actually quite scary I have to think
about what the truth is here it's just
like what would happen if you just
listened to positivity and optimism I
think so right like I get the listen
listen listen I'm worried I'm worried
that it gets into delusion and I think
the reason people resonate with me is
I'm not making it like it's the secret
and everything's gonna be okay I'm like
no it's hard it's work you might suck
but all you need is more optimism and
positivity and execution you're allowing
Chuck you were judged by something you
know and that's what you have to break
right that's what I'm hit my man you
were judged and that's what you're
imposing on yourself you need to break
that almost 90 listen eight out of ten
times you're judged by a parent or both
two out of ten times you are judged by
your environment I you don't you
understand you just need to like keep to
having this talk with me over and over
you know I just
I don't know it because for like writing
it something
don't know what's funny it's not writing
his time making videos this time
starting to travel stuff is tough being
24 is tough like it's tough for all of
us yeah guys I'm judged every day guys
go mean go read the reviews to crush it
on Amazon Corina go into one-star
reviews of how Amish I'm a snake oil
salesman and I'm a piece of [ __ ] I've no
I can't take two advil would I'll be
unconscious people think I'm on a how to
roll in coke every minute like it's
happening every day I get it and like
but you don't but like I don't expect
them to take the time to figure out who
I am yes I'm not mad at them I'm
empathetic I get that it's hard I know
um I know I'm completed but anyway dude
you're just you got judged
I love you guys I wish you guys well see
you guys good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]